[Music]
myself and some other members wanted to
create an atmosphere where police were
not so quick to go into our communities
and murder out people we thought it
reorganized patrols and our own
communities it would bring down the
percentages of police killings in our
neighborhood police always have what you
call an upper hand but when you have
armed militant black men who are
patrolling the communities that makes
them a lot less likely to commit
violence you could so long known that
there could be repercussions go 300 -
sweet - 300
[Music]
what we're trying to do is get black
people to understand their gun laws and
get black people to start organizing gun
clubs in the event there is some type of
emergency where we are attacked by white
supremacists or whomever it might be
that we're able to defend ourselves
[Music]
[Applause]
we're averaging anywhere from five to
seven new members per month I don't see
any change in membership because of
Donald Trump Donald Trump is not a
direct threat to us other than the
people that surround themselves around
the dumbest of Donald Trump ideology
[Music]